افادت مراسله الجزيره بان مجلس الحرب بدا
اجتماعه بمقر وزاره الدفاع في تلا ابيب
واوضحت ان المجلس الوزاري الامني المصغر
سينعقد بعده لبحث صفقه تبادل الاسرى
واوضحت القناه الثانيه عش الاسرائيلي ان
الاجتماع سيبحث عدد الاسرى الذين سيفرج
عنهم اذا اقرت الصفقه ونقلت القناه الثان
عش عن مصدر سياسي اسرائيلي تاكيده ان
الخلاف في المفاوضات سيكون بشان اسماء
الاسرى لا بشان
عددهم نقلت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه عن وزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي بليل سموتريتش قوله
انه لا يريد تضليل عائلات الرهائن وانه لن
يكون هناك اتفاق حسب اعتقاده واضاف
سموتريتش ان ادخال مساعدات الى غزه يتناقض
مع اهداف الحرب مضيفا انه تحدث الى رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو بشان
ذلك وسيتغير الوضع قريه
عن اجتماع مجلس الحرب وما سيعقده من
الاجتماع الوزاري المصغر معنا من تل ابيب
مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي امين ماذا عن
هذا الاجتماع حتى
الان نعم عبد القادر من المنتظر ان
يكون مجلس الحرب قد انهى اجتماعه في مبنى
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيلي هنا في تل ابيب
والان المجلس الوزاري المصغر الخاص
بالشؤون السياسيه والامنيه من المفترض ان
يكون قد بدا جلسته ايضا في ذات المبنى
بالتزامن مع مظاهرات خرجت لاهالي
ودوي الاسرى الاسرائيليين في قطاع
غزه قدر عددهم بنحو 250 متظاهرا رفعوا
شعارات تطالب الحكوم الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بابرام هذه الصفقه هناك في الحقيقه تباين
بشان هذه الصفقه بشان الشروط وايضا الشكل
النهائي الذي سيتم بحثه والذي من المنتظر
ان توافق عليه الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان كان
هناك طبعا اجماع حول الصيغه النهائيه في
نهايه المطاف هناك تصريحات بدت متباينه
هنا في اسرائيل بين انتقادات حاده
ل مساله اطلاق ال اطلاق طبعا الاسرى و
الموافقه على بعض الشروط
التي تقدمت بها حركه حماس وايضا هناك
لربما ضغوط سياسيه وعسكريه بدت واضحه خاصه
تلك التي جاءت على لسان وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يوف جالانت الذي اجرى اليوم
زياره تفقديه الى خان يونس جنوبي قطاع قع
غزه وقال بان هذا الضغط العسكري في خان
يونس متواصل وسيتم الانتقال فيما بعد الى
رفح وبان هذه العمليه العسكريه هي التي
ستقر اسرائيل بحسب
تعبيره من استعاده الاسرى من قطاع غزه هذه
التصريحات جاءت متناغمه مع تصريحات ايضا
سابقه كان وزير
الماليه او وزير الامن ال
الاسرائيلي بنفير قد ادلى بها في وقت سابق
قال بانه لن يسمح بوضع يتم فيه تقديم ظروف
ملائمه لحركه حماس من خلال هذه الصفح
الصفقه وطبعا هناك ايضا تصريحات اخرى ذهبت
في ذات الاتجاه وهذا لربما ما يبرز وجود
تباين كبير داخل اسرائيل بشان هذه الشروط
وايضا هناك ضغوط واضحه سياسيه وايضا
عسكريه من خلال التصريحات الصاد عن
المسؤولين لنا معك متابعه امين درغامي من
تلا ابيب